e o que aconteceria se você pudesse ver
o mundo com os olhos de outra pessoa
e esse é o meu pai ele já faleceu mas
ele era mais as pessoas mais reflexivas
que eu já conheci ele pensava muito
dormir a pouco ele falava menos ainda
mas ele tinha uma visão diferente do
mundo
e eu trabalhava cedo e quando eu
acordava e chegava na cozinha e ele já
estava lá com café preparado e com uma
cara de quem ficou a noite inteira
pensando em alguma coisa
em uma dessas manhãs ele pegou uma folha
de papel em branco assim como essa uma
caneta fez um pontinho
e me mostrou e disse filho que é isso
hoje eu olhei responde pai você é um
ponto
o filho olhe bem o que é isso pai isso é
um pontinho
e ele só respondia negativamente com a
cabeça até que me explicou filho isso é
uma folha porque a gente tem essa mania
de focar nesses detalhes tão
pequenininhos q nem fazem diferença que
nem são visíveis a uma certa distância o
pontinho não mudou que a folha é o que
ela foi criada para ser e nem o seu
valor isso continua sendo uma folha
o nosso papo acabou aí a sua cota de
palavra do dia já tinha se esgotado e eu
fui trabalhar solnado e impressionado
com a mente do meu pai que não parava de
trabalhar
há 20 anos se passaram e eu continuo
trabalhando no meu trabalho atual antes
de entrar neste emprego a gente passa
alguns dias cozinhando e servindo
pessoas eu trabalho no mcdonald's
e essa foi a foto de quando eu fiz isso
pela primeira vez e todos os anos a
gente repete esse ritual a última vez
que eu fiz isso eu fiquei no centro de
sobremesas e eu fiquei servindo sorvetes
deliciosos para os clientes queria
contar para vocês como foi essa
experiência eu servir mais de 60
sobremesas a mais de 40 clientes e
recebi um sorriso de um cliente
e antes que saia por aí mamãe chevette
dizendo diretor de marketing detona seus
consumidores eu queria esclarecer para
vocês que os nossos clientes pareciam os
mais felizes da praça de alimentação
ah mas de verdade essa experiência me
deu a certeza de como é difícil para
gente usar óculos eu não tô falando
deste equipamento zinho aqui para
corrigir a nossa visão ou não eu tô
falando dos óculos da compaixão e da
empatia
se você já fez exercício já tentou
imaginar nesta hora aí aonde você está
e como é viver como se você tivesse uma
deficiência física ou se você tivesse
uma grande dívida para pagar
o ou se você tivesse acabado de perder
um ente muito querido
em todas essas pessoas olham para o
mesmo mundo que você olha mas com olhos
diferentes nenhuma outra ocasião eu fui
conhecer uma faculdade quando eu cheguei
lá eu vi um monte de jovens tateando a
parede pessoas apalpando os corredores
falei que esquisito que que tá
acontecendo aqui alguém me explicou que
uma professora teve a ideia de pedir
para os alunos passarem 30 minutos com
os olhos vendados para experimentar em
como é viver como um cego
o que experiência isso deveria ser um
módulo obrigatório não acha não vi uma
faculdade mas pra vida já deu para
perceber que a nossa conversa de hoje
vai ser sobre empatia e quando fui
pesquisar sobre esse assunto achei um
monte de estudos interessantíssimos
análises psicológicas conclusões
neurológicas muito conteúdo legal mas se
eu fosse falar sobre isso para vocês
aqui hoje seria ser repetitivo o que
vocês conseguiram achar tudo isso na
internet facilmente a única coisa que
vocês não conseguiram descobrir sem a
minha ajuda é o que eu vou falar para
vocês aqui e a única coisa que vocês
precisam de mim para descobrir é o meu
ponto de vista pessoal sobre isso um
ponto de vista que é formado a partir de
um homem de fé filho marido pai e
marqueteiro isso mesmo eu sou
marqueteiro uma profissão que tem uma
reputação para
o vendedor de carro usado ou de advogado
de porta de cadeia mas que na verdade é
essencial para a gente conseguir
entender as necessidades dos clientes e
satisfazê-los eu já trabalhei com um
hamburguer batatinha sorvete
medicamentos escova de dente até mesmo
com produtos para beber antes de ser pai
e com absorventes femininos imagina o
que foi para mim tem que entender os
perrengues de uma menstruação ou como
foi entender a amamentação mas isso era
parte da minha descrição de cargo vestir
os sapatos dos clientes sente as suas
dores
é só que mesmo sendo pago para isso
confesso para vocês que até hoje tenho
que lutar contra aquela vontade de
deixar embalagem do big mac do jeito que
eu quero e não do jeito que os clientes
querem tenho certeza que é muito mais
difícil ver o mundo com os olhos dos
outros do que parece você já imaginou o
que aconteceria se o albert einstein
tivesse que olhar o mundo com os olhos
dos minions o que aconteceria se o tio
patinhas trocasse aqueles seus olhinhos
pelos olhos do chaves será que a sua
visão sobre o dinheiro seria diferente
ou se o poderoso super-homem tivesse
aqui usar os olhos do pantera negra ou
da mulher maravilha com o daria a sua
forma de olhar o mundo a sua forma de
agir como ele se sentiria estudos
mostram que quando você conta para
alguém o que está doendo em você o
ouvinte tem a mesma área do cérebro
ativado do que a pessoa que está
dolorida
e olha que coisa interessante quando
você tá assistindo televisão e você ver
uma pessoa tomando uma bolada no meio
das pernas e senti aquele frio na
barriga junto com ela isso é ciência
avançada na verdade isso é um chip
natural que nós temos que nos faz sentir
um gosto salgado na boca quando a gente
vê alguém chorando mas por alguma razão
a gente fica tentando abafar esse chip
parece que quem é capaz de sentir mais
as dores dos outros é uma pessoa
sensível demais muito compadecida uma
pessoa que carrega os fardos uns dos
outros mas eu não estou falando sobre
você pegar as dores dos outros para você
estou falando sobre a nossa capacidade
de nos conectarmos com as outras pessoas
de entendermos o que ela está vivendo de
entendermos como o seu coração está
batendo com dilatadas estão as suas
pupilas como está a sua respiração como
ela está se sentindo e por quê
e agindo daquela forma é fácil abrir a
boca de sono com quem está abrindo a
boca de sono mas não é nada fácil a
gente se alegrar de verdade com quem se
alegra e chorar com quem tá chorando
se você já imaginou por exemplo como
está agora se sentindo aquela sua
vizinha que é mãe de uma criança autista
o como está se sentindo agora um idoso
que está 90 dias sem poder sair de casa
por causa da quarentena ou como está se
sentindo alguém que sofreu abuso assédio
discriminação alguém que foi enganado
iludido desprezado ou alguém que viveu o
que você viveu vamos fazer uma atividade
prática eu queria te convidar a olhar
para você mesmo agora mas com os olhos
de outra pessoa por exemplo como será
que a sua esposa ou seu marido te ver
e pense nas principais características
que eles usariam para te descrever vou
confessar para você aqui se você
perguntar para minha esposa como ela me
ver ela provavelmente vai dizer o joão
pessoa bem-humorada trabalhadora
é teimosa e pão dura e a sua esposa ou
seu marido como se descreveria pensou
vamos mudar agora um pouco os óculos e o
seu chefe como ele olha para você como
ele ou ela que descreveria com os mesmos
adjetivos da sua esposa ou esse óleo de
uma forma diferente e uma última rodada
e a sua mãe como ela olha para você ela
olha como seu chefe como a sua esposa
como seu marido ou ela te olha como de
um jeito que só uma mãe conseguiria
fazer o fato é que todas as pessoas
olham para você de uma forma diferente
se você não muda quem você é por causa
das diferentes visões mas a relação que
você tem com cada uma delas muda dentre
todas essas visões no meu ponto de vista
a visão mais importante de todas é a
daquela pessoa que mais te ama e como um
homem de fé que diz que sou eu acredito
que exista um deus amoroso que te olha
com o maior amor de todos
oi eu queria te convidar hoje a tentar
usar os óculos dele e olhar para você
mesmo por alguns minutinhos como ele te
ver
e isso pode mudar a sua vida porque a
forma como ele ver você e como ele me
ver é a visão mais importante de todas
e isso me faz lembrar a história dessa
folha
e como será que a pessoa que inventou a
folha de papel olha para ela será que
ele tá se importando que aqui tem um
pontinho um detalhezinho vou ser aquele
olha com aquele orgulho da sua criação
sabendo que uma folha continua sendo uma
folha e que ela continua tendo o mesmo
valor não importa se ela tem um
detalhezinho aqui ou ali mas ela é a sua
criação amada da mesma forma acredito
que o nosso criador nos olha assim eu
gosto muito de ir ao cinema 3d porque
quando eu pego aqueles óculos especiais
não me lembro que na verdade existe uma
forma muito mais profunda a gente
conseguir enxergar as coisas parece que
existe uma outra dimensão a gente pode
ir muito além
e enquanto eu servia aquela sobremesas
os clientes não faziam ideia de que
talvez eu tivesse acordado as quatro
horas da manhã deixar uma criança doente
em casa pega uma condução lotada e
estava ali preocupado com questões
pessoais ele só queria uma sobremesa
deliciosa e eu só queria fazer um bom
trabalho mas eles não sabiam que um
sorriso faria tanta diferença ali no meu
dia deixaria tudo tão melhor e a gente
revele o tempo todo como a gente tá se
sentindo para as pessoas com a nossas
expressões faciais com os nossos gestos
com a nossa distância com nosso tom de
voz até com a nossa linguagem basta a
gente perceber
e por exemplo quando você pediu aquela
comida japonesa no delivery outro dia e
alguém da sua casa deu aquela primeira
bocada e fez uma cara assim de que isso
não está bom ela tava te salvando ali de
um momento ruim ela gritou para você com
as suas expressões faciais não como isso
aqui porque não tá muito legal só que
porque quando a sua esposa acorda com
aquela cara de mal humorada você prefere
deixar isso para lá e ativar o seu chip
no modo cada um com seus problemas e não
deixar aquilo estragar o seu dia a gente
tem essa mania de mudar a forma natural
do nosso chip e migrar ele para o modo
você que lute
ah mas isso não é a forma natural que
nós temos você conhece capivara sim eu
tô falando daquele bichinho talvez você
já tenha visto uma foto ou até um
pessoalmente toda vez que eu pergunto em
um grupo se o pessoal conhece capivara
todo mundo levanta a mão dizendo que sim
mas aí eu quero fazer mais algumas
perguntas por exemplo você sabe quantos
dentes tem na boca de uma capivara
quantos anos vive uma capivara qual é a
cidade que mais tem capivaras do brasil
quantos meses dura uma gestação de uma
capivara com essas perguntas fica claro
que a gente conhece muito pouco a
capivara a gente mais lemar sabe como é
o visual desse bichinho por alguma foto
vídeo um documentário que a gente tem
assistido não é mesmo agora e aquele seu
colega de trabalho você conhece ele você
conhece ele igual você conhece uma
capivara
a nossa capacidade de entender conhecer
profundamente as pessoas ao nosso redor
muito limitada a gente se contenta em
dizer que a gente conhece só de ouvir
falar a gente muito bom e descobrir onde
está o wally mas a gente não é tão bom
assim em perceber como o óleo está se
sentindo a verdade é que conhecer e
perceber as pessoas ao nosso redor é um
ato de humanidade é a opção nós podemos
fazer nenhum robô conseguiria fazer isso
é algo fundamental para o trabalho de um
marqueteiro mas também para qualquer
pessoa
se você já imaginou como seria o
melhores as propagandas se os
profissionais de marketing as empresas
entendesse de verdade e profundamente as
suas necessidades e tentar se conectar
com as suas emoções mas também já
imaginou como seria melhor as relações
se os moradores de um condomínio
conseguissem se sensibilizar com a forma
como o porteiro está hoje e vice-versa o
porteiro com o condômino ou como seriam
os casamentos se os maridos conseguissem
entender melhor as suas esposas e as
esposas melhores maridos no mínimo a
gente teria relações pessoais muito
melhores mas eu tô falando também de
algo que pode melhorar o mundo de alguma
forma
e talvez a forma mais fácil que a gente
tem de mudar o mundo que a gente vê é
mudar o ponto de onde a gente vê o mundo
você pode olhar pela sua janela da sua
casa e ver um tempo muito nublado
tenebroso acinzentado até mesmo chuvoso
e talvez se você der alguns passos para
sua direita para sua esquerda você vai
ver o mesmo céu só que agora
possivelmente ensolarado e tudo que você
fez foi mudar de ângulo mudar de ponto
mudar de lugar de onde você vê o mundo
quando a gente se permite colocar o
nosso ponto de vista um pouquinho na
gaveta para conhecer o ponto de vista do
outro isso é uma demonstração de amor
entender que o valor das pessoas não
muda por uma diferença física por uma
opinião diferente
e olha pessoal diferente por um pontinho
de vista diferente também é uma grande
demonstração de amor empatia não é um
dom que apenas algumas pessoas têm é uma
decisão é uma escolha que todos nós
podemos tomar de tentar olhar o mundo
com os olhos das pessoas que estão ao
nosso redor
e isso é capaz de abrir os nossos
horizontes e é capaz também de nos
permitir enxergar as necessidades das
pessoas isso permite fica muito mais
fácil que a gente possa ajudar aqueles
que estão precisando de ajuda ao nosso
redor e eu quero finalizar dizendo que
eu acho muito charmoso as pessoas que
usam óculos
e na verdade eu nunca precisei usar por
razões médicas esses aqui nem são meus
mas eu descobri que eu sempre precisei
usar por razões de amor ao próximo
é muito obrigado a
e aí